يقولان تعرضنا لمطارده شرسه من البابراتسي
ولكن هل هذا فعلا ما حدث
واغنيه تونسيه ساخره تسبب ازمه تصل
للنيابه والقضاء والرئاسه و 25 سؤال مع
المخرج النجم محمد سامي اهلا بكم
هلو ميجان والدراما قصه ما شكلها راح
تنتهي الثنائي موجودين حاليا في نيويورك
في نيويورك حصلت على جائزه واعطت خطا
والهنا ما في دراما الدراما صارت بعد ما
خلصوا الحفل وطلعوا فشفنا او في بيان على
لسان المتحدث باسمهم بيقول انهم تعرضوا
لمطارده كادت ان تكون كارثيه من مصورين
استمرت ساعتين وشارك فيها مصورين بسته
سيارات وعلى دراجات وانهم كانوا عدوانيين
وبيسوقوا بطريقه خطره جدا وقطعوا اشارات
حمراء ومشيوا عكس السير في شوارع اتجاه
واحد وعرضوا او وعرضوا وهاري ووالدتها
اللي كانت معهم للخطر ولكن ما اصيب باذى
المعلومات بعدين كشفت انه هاري وميجين
كانوا طالعين من الحفل فعلا وركبوا سياره
سوداء مضلله ولما شافوا المصورين
بيتسابقوا يصوروهم نزلوا من السياره
واخذوا تكسي علشان يتوهوا المصورين اللي
ما يبغوهم يستدلوا على مكان اقامتهم في
منزل احد اصدقائهم وفعلا في النهايه نجحوا
في انهم يتوهوهم طبعا خبر مثل هذا اكيد
راح يقلب الدنيا خاصه وان كلنا بنتذكر
طريقه وفاه والده هاري الاميره ديانا في
حادث في باريس تسبب في مصورين بابارتي او
على الاقل هذه هي الروايه الرسميه
المعتمده ولكن فجاه بدات تطلع اصوات تكذب
الثنائي وتنتقدهم فالناس صارت تقول ايش
معنى هم يعني من كل العيله المالكه اللي
بيصير معاهم كذا والناس الثانيه قالت كيف
مطارده سريعه وفي شوارع نيويورك اللي
معروفه بالازدحام الشديد ومن بينها دوله
راح حاكم نيويورك نفسه اللي انسال على
الموضوع في مؤتمر صحفي
مثل ما شفتوا حاكم نيويورك قال يعني صعب
نصدق انهم كانوا ساعتين في مطارده بس على
العموم حيحققوا في الموضوع والتحقيقات هذه
على فكره بحسب الشرطه راح تشوف المواد
اللي تصورت وتشوف كاميرات المراقبه في
الشوارع والشرطه قالت انه هذا التحقيق ما
طلبوا هاري اوميجا موضوع مين طلب التحقيق
كان مسار كلام خاصه وانه الامير ان شاف في
بعض الصور بيصور اللي بيحصل معاهم في
تلفونه او عن طريق تليفونه الشخصي رد اخر
طلع كمان كان من احد اكبر شركات التصوير
في امريكا وهي شركه اللي طلعت او طلعت
بيان قالت فيه انه اربع مصورين بيتعاملوا
معاها زودوها بصور وانهم كانوا في الواقع
وانه ثلاثه منهم كانوا في سيارات وواحد في
دراجه وانهم كانوا بيغطوا زياره الثنائي
لنيويورك وقالت انهم ما كانوا قاصدين اي
ضرر للثنائي وكل ادواتهم كانت كاميراتهم
وقالت انهم دايما بيغطوا او اخبار متعلقه
بشخصيات عامه وانهم مهنيين ومتدربين كويس
والمفاجاه الاكبر كانت لما طلع سواق
التاكسي نفسه اللي كان سايق في هاري
اوميجا في مقابلات عديده مع عده صحف
ووسائل الاعلام وقال انه مش عارف في اي
لحظه انه في اي خطر وانه الكلام اللي
قالوا مبالغ فيه
تاكسي
[موسيقى]
في كلام كثير حول العالم مؤخرا عن زياده
في الوفيات المفاجئه وناقشنا الموضوع في
حلقه من كم يوم خاصه انه في عالمنا العربي
الموضوع كثر الحديث عنه بعد وفاه عدد من
المشاهير مؤخرا وبشكل فجائي اخرهم الفنان
السعودي فهد الحيان المصري مصطفى درويش
قبله الفنانين السوريين محمد قنوع وشادي
زيدان وغيرهم الموضوع ناقشنا مع استشاري
امراض قلب وشرايين من كم يوم واتكلم معانا
انه فعلا البيانات حول العالم بتظهر انه
في زياده فعلا في الوفيات بين الشباب
واعطانا كمان اسباب لهذا الشيب بعد ما
نزلنا الفقره لاحظنا انه كثير من
تعليقاتكم مشاهدينا تساءلت عن جانب معين
وهو كورونا ولقاح كورونا كثير كان في
تساؤلات عن العلاقه بينهم وبين الزياده في
الوفيات المفاجئه في العالم فرجعنا كلمنا
الدكتور اسلام وطلبنا منه انه يرد علينا
وهذا كان جوابه
في الواقع نحن تعلمنا في حقبه كورونا
ان مرض كوفي 19
قد يكون متسبب بارتفاع معاملات التجلط في
الجسم وقد يؤدي الى
اصابه بنوبات قلبيه اكثر لدى المصابين
بمرض كورونا او قد يتسبب نفسه باصابه
بجلطات قلب جلطات رئويه او جلطات في اماكن
اخرى من الجسم
الحديث عن موضوع المطاعيم نفسها انها قد
تكون مؤثر سلبي او قد تتسبب لاحقا في
حالات من الجلطات او توقف القلب او
النوبات القلبيه المفاجئه حديث طويل وشائك
علميا اود ان انبه ان الحالات المرتبطه
بالمطاعيم هي حالات
اناس لديهم الاستعداد
لحدوث مثل هذا النوع من التجلط سواء قلبيا
او رئويا او تجلط في اماكن اخرى من الجسم
وهو مشابه لحاله قد تسبب فيها حتى بعض
[موسيقى]
المميعات في الدم مثل ماده الهيبرين وهم
معروف انه هو مسيل للدم وعلى العكس ما
يحصل عند بعض الناس هبوط في الصفائح
الدمويه مما تساعد على خلق حاله مناعيه
تؤدي الى احداث حاله من التجلط
نفس هذا النوع قد يكون قد يكون مصاحب
للتجلطات المصاحبه لبعض المطاعيم كورونا
لكن بالعاده لا تتسبب
التوقف
المفاجئ للقلب
المشاهدات اغلبها حالات تخثر سواء تجلطات
ورديه او جلطات رئويه ونادر جدا ما تكون
اصابات
بنوبات قلبيه
واعتقادي العلمي بناء على كثير من
الدراسات ان هؤلاء الذين اصيبوا بمثل هذه
الاصابه كان لديهم استعداد
جسدي اكثر من غيرهم بعوامل معينه وان
وراثيه او جينيه لديهم الاستعداد لحدوث
مثل هذه النوبات ولم يثبت ان هذه المطاعيم
هي بشكل واضح او مباشر المتسبب بحدوث
نوبات قلبيه او توقف مفاجئ للقلب او حدوث
وفاء مبكره او متسببه بالوفاه المفاجئه
اهلا من جديد تونس لها كم يوم من السلطه
مشغوله بسبب اغنيه ساخره اغنيه وصلت
للنيابه والقضاء والرئاسه وفتحت نقاشات
على اعلى المستويات الاغنيه اطلقها شابين
اسمهم يوسف شلبي وضياء نصير عمرهم 26 و 27
سنه وهم من محافظه نابل شمال شرق تونس
والاغنيه الساخره اسمها بابا في الليل
يلوج في الاقليم والاغنيه بتنتقد سلوك
الشرطه وقانون استهلاك المخدرات وكلمات
على الحان اغنيه كرتون بابار الشهير
والاغنيه انتشرت من هنا وانقبض على
الشابين من هنا
مره في حينا زارنا الحاكم في الليل هد
علينا بالدار عدي
نا الكود
منين
[موسيقى]
عندو
ما
يعرفو جي نهارين ما يعرف
مره في حينا
اللي بيغنوا الاغنيه انقبض عليهم وهم
طالعين من مقهى بعد ما اعتبر عناصر في
شرطه نابل ان الاغنيه فيها اساءه للغير
ونشر امور غير صحيحه عن موظف عمومي ومع
انتشار خبر القبض عليهم انتفضت المنصات
غضب وتنديد باعتقال الشباب خاصه من قبل
الناس اللي شايفه انهم ما عملوا شيء
والاغنيه ساخره وناس تانيه بتقول فين حريه
التعبير وشباب اطلقوا حمله اسمها سيب
الشباب يعني فلتو الشباب حمله الانتقادات
هذه للقبض على الشباب استجابه لها وزاره
الداخليه اللي اعلن الناطق الرسمي باسمها
انه الوزير امر بفتح بحث اداري حول عمليه
توقيف الشباب للتثبت في حيثياتها وبعد
الرئيس بنفسه قيس سعيد طلع في تصريحات وقف
فيها لجانب الشعب والشباب وانتقد فيها
اعتقالهم
اعبر عن شديد الاستغراب من اعتقالي عدد من
التلاميذ او الطلبه بنابل لا اتدخل في
القضاء ولكن لا اريد ان يظلم احد في هذه
البلاد
نحترم القضاء ولكن نحترم القضاء المستقل
ليس هناك اي مبرر على الاطلاق
لاعتقالي طلبه وهم يستعدونه لاجراء
الامتحانات اما حصله غير مقبول وعلى
القضاه الشرفاء ان يتصدوا لمثل هذه
التجاوزات وعلى المجلس الاعلى للقضاء ان
يقوم بدوره كاملا في
ضمان العدل لكل التونسيين من نهب الدوله
ومن نهب المجتمع خارج السجون ومن
كان في بيته ورددوا اغنيه ما هو السبب
للاعتقال حتى على افتراض انهم
قاموا بجرم على اقتراض
لماذا الاحتفاظ بهم
لماذا التنكير بهم
هذه الرساله واضحه لاننا اننا لن نسكت
ابدا عن الظالمين
ولن نسكت ابدا عن حقوق المظلومين
واخر تطورات القضيه انه من اقل من ساعتين
اعلن فريق الدفاع عن الشابين الافراج عنهم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام حلقتنا لليوم وهذا
الاسبوع ومن بعد غياب في موسم رمضان نعود
لفقرتنا الاسبوعيه 25 سؤال ضفنا هذا
الاسبوع المخرج النجم محمد سامي انا
اترككم مع المقابله والقاكم الاحد ان شاء
الله في امان الله
محمد سامي 25 سؤال لازم نجاوب عليهم بسرعه
من غير تفكير عمل صنع اسمك
ادم مين الاكثر نرجسيه انت او محمد رمضان
طيب كده كده واحد فيكم بس
ما حدش
طيب ايش اللحظه اللي قررت انك تتزوج فيها
مي عمر لاول مره شفتها اوف على طول اول
مره هل ممكن ترجع تشتغل مع الفنان غاده
عبد الرازق لا انت متهم انك من اكثر
المخرجين عصبيه وبتصرخ كثير في اللوكيشن
وبتشتم صح او غلط او كيف بترد ما بتشتغل
عشان الشغل بكون عايز الشغل يمشي بشكل
كويس فده بيعمل حلقه من الاستراس لان
بيبقى مهموم الشغل اللي انا بعمله اوكي
طيب عملت تندم عليه
يعني في عمل بس ما تبي تقوله اوكي
طيب كده اوكي يلا فنان او فنانه تعتقد انك
لو اشتغلت معاهم حتظهرهم بشكل مختلف عبله
كامل اهم نصيحه حصلت عليها
[موسيقى]
كتير بس يعني واحده بس ايوه واحده كده
دايما تتذكرها او تعتقد انها بالنسبه لك
عماد زياده قال لي لما جيت ارجع تاني بعد
الظرف بتاع الناس الاغراب قال لي يعني اما
ترجع ما تخليش في قلبك حقد او كراهيه او
اروح انتقام خلي عندك حب اوكي طيب قضيه
ترغب في تسليه الضوء عليها
[موسيقى]
كل كل بحب قوي قضيات اللي لها علاقه يعني
بحب اي قضيه لها علاقه بالمراه هي قضيه
لها علاقه بحقوق المراه واحترام المراه او
معامله المراه بشكل احسن او تمكينها اكتر
في المجتمع ممتاز ليش دايما بيقال انه
عندك مشاكل كثيره مع الناس لا والله ابدا
هو بس دايما الحياه لما بيكون الواحد
حياته موجود حواليها ان هو معروف او مشهور
بيحصل خلاف الخلاف دوت بيتبروز بشكل كبير
قوي فبيحسس الناس ان هو خلافات كتير بس هو
خلافات مع الاشخاص انا بشتغل الشغلانه
الواحده بيكون معي حوالي 700 بني ادم في
العرب ما بين فنانين وما بين فنانين اكيد
مش كل الناس هيتفقوا علي ومش كل الناس
هتتفق معهم يمكن انا كمان في وقت وانا
اصغر كانت ضد افعالي بتكون اعنف فبكبر
المشكله دلوقتي اعتقد اننا في مرحله عمريه
مختلفه مين اشطر محمد سامي المخرج او
المؤلف
محمد سامي المؤلف شغال عند محمد سامي
المخرج
فالمخرج يعني هو الاشطر اللي بيتحكم
اهم شيء نفسك تعلموا البناتك
وربنا سبحانه وتعالى
اخراج الاغاني المصوره ما بيعتبر تقليل من
موهبتك
انا بدات فيها انا بدات فيها انا تعرفت
عشان انا مخرج الاغاني المصوره فحتى
للناس اي حاجه انا بحترمها طول الوقت بدات
بها اوكي وممكن ده حلو احد مثلا مطرب كلمك
مثلا ممكن تعملها حسب هو مين يعني انا
عملت كده من قريب كذا مره بس حسب هو مين
اكيد لكل مرحله لها شغل ينفع تعمليه شغل
لا اجمل صفه ماي عمر كلها كل صفاتها هدوء
مي احلى صفه فيها هدوءها مش مش انفعاليه
ومش ومش
ميه هاديه شخص متزن الاتزان ده هو احسن
حاجه فيها اوكي اصعب موقف مر عليك
موت اختي الله يرحمها الله يرحمها طيب
اعمال محمد سامي ناجحه ولكنها تجاريه
وللاستهلاك السريع وليست للزمن كيف بترد
اعمال محمد سامي للاستهلاك السريع ما كناش
بقيناه فاكرين الاسطوره لغايه دلوقتي
ما كناش فاكرين ادم لغايه دلوقتي سبق
لغايه دلوقتي لا العمل الاستهلاك ده ده
بيقول له الحاجات ديت الناس اللي بتكون
زعلانه او ما حققتش نفس النجاح فبتحاول
تقلل من نجاح الاشخاص انما مش مظبوط من
اهم مخرج مصري في اخر خمسين سنه
في اخر خمسين سنه لا هو في كتير قوي وده
سؤال يعني اترد عليه ما ينفعش في 25 سؤال
ده سؤال عايز لوحده ساعه ونص لوحده عشان
نقول لا مصر
عندي عندي اساتذه كتير اتعلمت منهم كلهم
ازاي افضل فيهم حد عن التاني كل واحد
اتعلمت منه حاجه انواع مختلفه مش كلهم
بيقدموا نفس الحاجه مصر بلد العظماء مصر
بلد المخرجين العظماء كل اساتذتي وكل
زمايلي عظماء كلهم فما اقدرش انقي شخص
واحد منهم باظلم للاخرين او عدم احترام
للاخرين مصر فيها اساتذه كتير اقوى جمله
كتبتها
كل واحد بيشوف الناس من عين طبعه
باعي بتقول ما مانع اعمل مع محمد سامي في
عمل ولكن عمل ليس فيه مي عمر كيف ترد ربنا
يكرمها ويوف
قه ان شاء الله واضح انه مش هتشتغل لا معك
لو عمل فيه مي عمر ولا عمل ما فيه ما يعمر
لو في دورها اكيد انا بحترم الناس
والمواهبهم يعني لو في اي دور شبهها اكيد
هجيبها ايه علاقه ده تقول اللي هي عايزه
تقوله اكيد ده مش يعني مش مركز مع اللي هي
بتقول بصراحه اوكي هل الناجح في مصر محارب
في مصر
[موسيقى]
محمد رمضان محمد هنيدي احمد حلمي النجاح
في مصر دايما بيدعم الناجح في العالم كله
الحاقدين بيحاربوه لما نجح في مصر بيدعم
من الشعب ومن الدوله والفنيين
في العالم كله اوكي طيب فيلم او مسلسل كنت
اتمنى لو كان لك
فيلم او مسلسل اتمنى لو كان لو مسلسل اي
مسلسل استاذ محمود عبد العزيز رحمه الله
عليه الله يرحمه لو فيلم اي فيلم استاذ
عادل امام رحمه
يا رب ويحفظك
يعني الاستاذ عادل امام والاستاذ وحيد
حامد
متى اخر مره بكيت
تقريبا في الحلقه
لا اخر مره بكيت وانا بمنتج لسه من قريب
في مشهد بتاع محمد رمضان واحمد فهيم وانا
ايديت مع استاذه العظيمه غاده عز الدين
وانا قاعد بتفرج على السين افطر
هل صحيح انك تكتب او لما تكتب دائما
بتتخيل انه بطله العمل هي مي عمر حتى لو
ما كان العمل لها طبعا لان انا بكتب
بطريقه مؤلف غريبه شويه انا بكتب بطريقه
مخرج
ببص بتفرج وبشوف فدائما بشوف الفيديوهات
هي البطله اللي بشوفها هي البطله حياتي
كلها اللي هي مي عمر اصعب مشهد صورته
في حياتي وانا في العمل الاخير
اصعب مشهد صورته
[موسيقى]
طب اصعب معلش انا عارف ان هو 25 سؤال بس
اصعب من حيث ايه اصعب من حيث المجهود ولا
اصعب
ممكن نفسيا كان عليك صعب ممكن مشهد يعني
كان منحوس بشكل رهيب كمجهود وانا بصور
الاغاني بتاعه مسلسل لؤلؤ الاغاني كانت كل
اغاني مي ونرمين الفقي وكل الاستعراضات
كانوا في يومين على كرومات وفيهم شغل
جرافيكس كتير جدا فدوق كان اصعب يعني
كانوا يومين مش قادميين يعني طيب شو
المسلسل طلع حلو
طيب هل محمد سامي المخرج الاعلى اجرا في
مصر معرفش اقول زمايلي وانا يعني معرفش بس
موضوع الاجور ده يعني حاجه لها علاقه
بالارز وكده انا مش عارف فعلا
والله يعني الحمد لله اللي بيرضيني ولا
بيخلي بيتي ماشي بشكل كويس والحمد لله انا
مبسوط به بس يعني حاجه حاجه بيني وبينك
اوكي
شكرا يا محمد كانوا سريعين
[موسيقى]